und wir melden uns wieder aus dem
Deutschen Bundestag mit einer aktuellen
Stunde zum Thema der Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgericht von gestern zum
Nachtragshaushalt 2021 ein Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgericht das gestern für
viel Unruhe gesorgt hat denn es ist klar
dass der Bundeshaushalt
2021 der aus Reaktion auf die
coronapandemie die vorgesehene
kreditermächtigung von 60 Milliarden
rückwirkend auf den Energie und klimaf
nicht undzu Fried CDU
oppositionführer dass sie das
Grundgesetz verletzen zur Erinnerung
kurz vor den Sommerferien mussten sie
die Abstimmung über das sogenannte
heizungsgesetz verschieben weil sie den
Abgeordneten des Deutschen Bundestages
in verfassungswiedriger Weise
Mitspracherechte vorenthalten haben und
gestern ist festgestellt Verfassungs
Weise Mitspracherechte vorenthalten
haben Herr Kollege und dieser Zustand
hält an ich komme darauf gleich noch zu
sprechen und gestern haben sie bestätigt
bekommen dass sie im letzten Jahr einen
Nachtragshaushalt für das Jahr
2021 aufgestellt haben der vom
Verfassungsgericht nicht nur als
verfassungswidrig angesehen worden ist
sondern als nichtig und das heißt von
Anfang an vom ersten Tag an unwirksam
meine Damen und Herren beide
Entscheidungen
beide Entscheidungen so unterschiedlich
die Streitgegenstände auch sind beide
Entscheidungen haben eines gemeinsam sie
offenbaren das Verständnis der
Regierungsfraktionen dass sie sich im
Grunde genommen mit ihrer Mehrheit hier
im Deutschen Bundestag über alle Regeln
auch über die Regeln eingeübter
parlamentarischer Praxis und jetzt auch
über die Regeln der Schuldenbremse des
Grundgesetzes einfach so hinwegsetzen
können sie wischen sie wischen alle
Einwände sie wischen alle Einwände die
gegen ihre Politik vorgetragen werden
einfach zur Seite und selbst nach diesen
beiden Entscheidungen geht das bei ihnen
einfach so weiter beim heizungsgesetz
haben sie uns gönnerhaft etwas mehr Zeit
zum Lesen gegeben und anschließend alles
so entschlossen und entschieden ohne
weitere Beratungen wie sie es vorher
vorgehabt haben und jetzt
hier und jetzt
hier Bundeshaushalt 2024 setzen sie seit
gestern die Beratungen fort so als ob es
die Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes vom gestrigen
Tag überhaupt nicht gegeben hätte meine
Damen und Herren sie wissen dabei
spätestens seit gestern sie wissen
spätestens seit gestern dass sie im
nächsten Jahr einen Nachtragshaushalt
aufstellen müssen weil sie einfach die
eingegangenen Verpflichtungen aus dem
KTF aus dem Klima und
transformationsfond jetzt wenigstens
teilweise in einen regulären Haushalt
überführen müssen Sie wissen es wer aber
schon vor der Verabschiedung eines
regulären Haushaltes weiß dass er einen
Nachtragshaushalt beraten und
verabschieden muss der verstößt erneut
gegen die Grundsätze der
haushaltswahrheit und der
haushaltsklarheit gegen Grundsätze die
nun spätesten seit gestern spätestens
seit gestern so gut wie
verfassungsrank haben meine Damen und
Herren der Bundeskanzler hat von dieser
Stelle aus am 27 Februar 2022 eine
eindrucksvolle Regierungserklärung
abgegeben und eine Zeitenwende
beschrieben die Zeitenwende hat bei
ihnen bisher darin bestanden dass Sie
zusätzliche Schulden machen und einen
Teil davon sogar mit unserer Zustimmung
in Form eines Sondervermögens in das
Grundgesetz der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland aufnehmen alles andere haben
sie so weiter gemacht wie vorher sie
haben es ja sogar
entlich bei jeder Gelegenheit zugesagt
dass sich nichts ändern wird außer
zusätzlichen Schulden meine Damen und
Herren liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der ampelfraktion die Zeitenwende ist
spätestens seit gestern auch für Sie
Realität sie kommen jetzt nicht mehr um
hin zu akzeptieren dass sie die
Prioritäten ihres Haushaltes unseres
Haushaltes der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland neu ordnen müssen fangen Sie
damit so früh wie möglich an damit dies
auch zu einem Erfolg werden kann und
lassen Sie mich abschließend eines
sagen wir stehen wir stehen in
Deutschland vor schweren politischen
Zeiten außenpolitisch innenpolitisch und
gesellschaftspolitisch kehren sie kehren
sie mit ihren
Verhaltensweisen sowohl zu
verfassungskonformer Gesetzgebung zurück
und kehren Sie auch zu den mindestregeln
zurück eines vernünftigen parlamentar
Miteinanders hier im Deutschen Bundestag
damit unsere Institutionen nicht noch
mehr Schaden nehmen und damit das
Vertrauen in die Politik unseres Landes
nicht noch mehr leidet so wie sie
gegenwärtig hier in Deutschland arbeiten
wir sind dazu bereit das zu tun aber
spätestens spätestens seit gestern ist
klar spätestens seit gestern ist klar
dass sie wesentliche Merkmale ihres
Arbeitens ihrer Politik ändern müssen
wenn das ein gemeinsamer g für unser
Land werden soll herzlichen Dank
Friedrich Merz zum Auftrag dieser
aktuellen Stunde die auf Antrag der CDU
CSU in den Bundestag heute in die
Tagesordnung aufgenommen wurde und es
waren auch 197 Bundestagsabgeordnete
dieser Fraktion die in Karlsruhe eben
geklagt hatten gegen die rückwirkende
Änderung des Haushaltsgesetzes und
dadurch fehlen der Koalition der
Regierungskoalition jetzt 60 Milliarden
Euro für den Klima und
transformationsfond
langer Applaus für Friedrich märz das
Plenum hat sich auch wieder gut gefüllt
anlässig dieser aktuellen Stunde jetzt
erwidert Achim Post von der SPD
stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren vielleicht zum Kern des Urteils
von gestern das Verfassungsgericht hat
gestern ein grundlegendes Urteil zum
Klima und transformationsfond gesprochen
und die
Bundesregierung die Bundesregierung hat
klar und
deutlich gesagt und erklärt dass sie
selbstverständlich dieses Urteil
beachtet und umsetzen
wird das das kann man das kann man am
Anfang ruhig noch mal sagen ne und das
gleiche gilt selbstverständlich für die
SPD Bundestag e K Kollegen deshalb bin
ich Bundeskanzler Scholz
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner und
Bundeswirtschaftsminister ausdrücklich
dankbar dafür dass sie gestern gemeinsam
besonnen und klar auf das Urteil
reagiert haben das ist genau die
richtige Haltung das ist genau das
richtige Vorgehen und das hat genau die
volle Unterstützung meiner Fraktion
liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen dar
hinaus
her und verantwortungsvolle Prüfung des
Urteils und seiner tieferliegenden
Folgen eben weil es ein grundlegendes
Urteil ist eben weil sich das
Verfassungsgericht überhaupt das erste
Mal grundlegen zu Fragen der
Schuldenregeln und der Nutzung von
Sondervermögen geäußert hat und eben
weil es ein Urteil ist das nicht nur
Auswirkung auf den Bund hat sondern auch
auf die Länder liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und eins ist auch klar Schnellschüsse
wären jetzt nicht seriös sie wären der
Tragweite der Entscheidung nicht
angemessen das gilt für die Regierung
das gilt für die
Regierungsfraktionen das gilt für die
Oppositionsfraktion jetzt ist nicht die
Zeit für politische Winkelzüge sondern
für kluges Handeln und staatspolitische
Verantwortung lieber Herr Kollege
Merz mit dem Urteil mit dem Urteil von
gestern liegen jetzt erstmals
höchstrichterliche Leitplanken vor wie
die Schuldenregeln unserer Verfassung zu
interpretieren und anzuwenden sind
ja ja ja sie wussten alles vorher das
ist jetzt die Stunde der besser Wisser
und neun Mal klugen und neunmal klug
alles klar sie war noch nie dabei sie
haben noch nie regiert in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere sie waren nie in der
großen Koalition mit
uns und deshalb erst jetzt mit dem
Urteil aus Karlsruhe gibt es nun diese
Grundlagen erst jetzt gibt es einen
höchstrichterlichen Rahmen zur Anwendung
der Schuldenregeln dazu ist noch etwas
wichtig dazu ist noch etwas wichtig das
klare Signal dass diese Regierung diese
Koalition unser Staat weiter
handlungsfähig sind liebe Kolleginnen
und
Kollegen wir werden deshalb wir werden
deshalb diesen Bundeshaushalt im
vorgesehenen Zeitrahmen verabschieden
und wir werden damit am 1 Dezember einen
Bundeshaushalt annehmen der auch
weiterhin starke Zukunftsinvestitionen
vorsehen wird der auch weiter starke
Investition in die innere und und äußere
Sicherheit unseres Landes vorsehen wird
und der auch weiterhin starke
Instrumente für den sozialen
Zusammenhalt in unserem Land vorsehen
wird im übrigen im übrigen es war das
Bundesverfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe
das in einer anderen wegweisenden
Entscheidung aus dem Jahr
2021 den Klimaschutz als elementare
zukunftsverantwortung aus unserer
Verfassung hergeleitet hat ein
handlungsau an die Politik der weiter
Bestand hat ein Handlungsauftrag der
weiter durch mutiges Handeln politisch
zu füllen ist und ein Handlungsauftrag
der weiter erhebliche finanzielle
Ressourcen verlangen wird denn eins ist
doch klar eins ist meiner Fraktion eins
ist der Ampel völlig klar Klimaschutz
und sozialer Zusammenhalt dürfen nicht
die Verlierer
sein deshalb deshalb
zusammenfasst es geht jetzt darum
erstens das Urteil zu beachten und
umzusetzen zweitens mit besonenheit mit
besondnenheit ich weiß es für manche ein
Fremdwort mit besondnenheit die
längerfristigen Schlussfolgerungen zu
ziehen und drittens bei alledem die
handlungs und Zukunftsfähigkeit unseres
Landes sicherzustellen die SPD Fraktion
im Deutschen Bundestag wird deshalb
alles dafür tun dass uns genau das auch
gelingen wird und Liebe Kolleginen und
Kollegen es wird
gelingen soweit auch im Post von der SPD
gestern hat der Bundeskanzler als
Reaktion auf auf dieses Urteil gesagt
das Urteil bedeute eine tiefgreifende
Änderung der Haushalte von Bund und
Ländern es Gebiete sich aber kein
schnellschust trotzdem soll der Haushalt
verabschiedet werden Anfang Dezember
jetzt Peter böringer von der AFD der
haushaltspolitische Sprecher das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat ein für uns
nicht überraschendes Urteil verkündet
schon der allererste ampelhaushalt
damals 2122 wurde für verfassungswidrig
und sogar nichtig erklärt ich verweise
bezüglich der 60 Milliarden
zusatzverschuldung die von ihen
2022 im nachtragshaushaltsgesetz 21
durchgesetzt wurde auf unseren damaligen
Entschließungsantrag 20488 wir haben
dort nicht nur das Urteil sondern sogar
exakt fast exakt die drei
begründungsteile von karlsruh
vorausgesagt nicht weil wir eine
Kristallkugel gehabt hätten oder
irgendwie überragende Juristen sondern
weil die rechtliche Lage damals schon
völlig klar war wir formulierten
wörtlich damals im Antrag das Gesetz
verstößt in geradezu
offensichtlicherweise gegen zentrale
verfassungsrechtlich verankerte
Grundsätze des
Haushaltsrechts man kann es darum
eigentlich nur mit frechem Vorsatz
erklären dass die ampelregierung
praktisch mit ihrer allerersten
Amtshandlung zwingende Vorschriften des
Grundgesetzes schlicht missachtet
hat die Ampel wollte
2022 unbedingt die 60 Milliarden Euro an
2021 noch möglichem Zusatzkredit
aufnehmen obwohl das Jahr 21 bereits
vorbei war und obwohl die CO2
ideologisch begründeten Ausgaben
keinerleif
Veranlassungszusammenhang mit Corona
hatten es ist weiterhin sehr positiv
dass mit dem Urteil nun auch endlich die
von uns seit ihrer Einführung für
verfassungswiedrig erkannte
verbuchungssystematik von Schulden in
Sondervermögen außerhalb der
Schuldenbremse beendet wird Herr Post es
geht weit über die 60 Milliarden hinaus
das erkennt nun offensichtlich auch der
Finanzminister gestern Abend im
Haushaltsausschuss sagte her Lindner das
Urteil bewerrte die Staatspraxis neu nun
eigentlich nicht Herr Lindner es stellt
die seit 2021 praktizierte illegale
staatsprakis aller Altparteien inklusive
CDU wieder zurück auf rechtmäßige
Füße lesen Sie hierzu unbedingt das
ganze Urteil len Sie das Ganze Urteil
der von ihnen allen von ihnen allen
angewandte Trick der überjährigen
Rücklagenbildung auf Pump zur Nutzung
nach dem offiziellen Ende einer
Notsituation war rückblickend generell
verfassungswidrig damit unter anderem
auch 170 Milliarden an kreditfinanzierte
Reserve zuuführung zum WSF im
Haushaltsjahr 22 und übrigens auch schon
die 26 Milliarden Rücklagenbildung im
EKF Fond durch die CDU geführte
Regierung im Nachtragshaushalt
2020 lassen Sie mich dazu lassen sie
mich die starken Worte eines Kollegen
zitieren gerichtet damals am 2 juli 2020
sich an Finanzminister Scholz heute
legen Sie einen Nachtragshaushalt vor er
verstößt gegen das Grundgesetz der
zweite Nachtragshaushalt beeinträchtigt
wesentliche Verfassungsgrundsätze wie
Jährlichkeit Wahrheit und Klarheit ich
verstehe nicht wie man in der SPD
Karriere machen kann oder nur Karriere
machen kann wenn man verfassungswidrige
Haushalte vorlegt ich verstehe nicht
warum die CDU CSU Bundestagsfraktion
hier zum Helfershelfer eines möglichen
verfassungsbrechers wird ich halte das
für einen gigantischen Fehler Herr
reberg klammert CDU Ende des Zitats das
wurde damals auch exakt so von mir und
den AFD vertreten das Zitat aber stammt
vom heutigen FDP Fraktionschef Christian
D schön dass sie noch zu uns gefunden
haben leider hat die FDP in der Ampel
ihr damaliges wissen dann sofort
vergessen
Herr der vorgelegte Haushalt 24 wird
wegen der darin verwendeten Budget
buchungspraxis vom Tag seiner
Verabschiedung an verfassungsrechtlich
angreifbar sein ich frage Sie darum alle
wie lang soll die Unsitte solcher
Sondervermögen mit nicht legal gemäß
Artikel 115 Grundgesetz verbuchten
Krediten noch anhalten wie lange wollen
Sie das noch durchziehen es läuft schon
seit Jahren im Klima und
transformationsvor führt das Urteil das
ist ja rechtlich unstrittig mathematisch
und rechtlich dazu dass ihrem
wichtigsten lebenhaushalt schon 2024 das
Geld ausgehen wird meine Fraktion fände
das zwar gesagt nicht so tragisch weil
es sich dabei ohnehin fast nur um
ideologisch begründete fehlausgaben
handelt der aktuell vorleegende
ampelhaushalt kann aber nach diesem
Urteil nun nicht wie vorgestellt
verabschiedet werden wir fordern wie
schon länger die fast völlige Löschung
aller ktf-titel und wir fordern eine
Neuaufsetzung eines haushaltsprozesses
24 unter Anrechnung der Kredite der
Sondervermögen auf die
Schuldenbremse eine auf Deutschland
fokussierte Regierung müsste seit Jahren
keine Abgaben erhöhen und ohne verfehlte
eurorettungs cororona Energie und
gesellschaftsideologien auch keine
illegalen Schulden machen machen sie
endlich unideologische und
rechtskonforme Politik zum nationalen
wohl Deutschlands herzlichen
Dank der nächste Redner kommt von
Bündnis 90 90 bundes90 die grün Andreas
audritch stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende und wir hatten auch
wieder ein Wechsel im Präsidium jetzt
hat Petra Pau den
[Applaus]
Vorsitz frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes ist klar und
so klar sind die Anpassungen die wir
jetzt in der Haushaltspolitik vornehmen
der Finanzminister hat die notwendigen
Maßnahmen ergriffen 60 Milliarden stehen
im Klima und transformationsfond nicht
mehr zur Verfügung das ist konsequent
und das ist richtig so gleichzeitig
sorgen wir parallel dafür dass die
Haushaltsberatungen hier im Deutschen
Bundestag seriös und
verantwortungsvoll abgeschlossen werden
das ist Verantwortung in dieser Zeit und
genau diese Verantwortung übernehmen wir
als Ampelkoalition
gemeinsam und dann steht die große
Frage wir
Deutschlands im Raum und die geht uns
alle etwas an die geht übrigens auch die
Union etwas an und an der Stelle sehr
geehrte Herr Merz war ihre Rede nicht
mehr als ein blanker Offenbarungseid sie
haben nicht einen einzigen Vorschlag
dazu vorgelegt wie man in irgendeiner
Form die Fragen die sich jetzt in
unserem Land Stellen lösen lösen könnte
nichts da war nicht ein Vorschlag das
reih sich übrigens ein in das was sie
seit Z Jahren machen immer nur
luftbuchung nichts vorschlagen was man
tun könnte gleichzeitig blockieren sie
sie als Union jetzt im Ausschuss die
Beratungen des Haushaltes für Sie
handeln unverantwortlich sie machen
keinerlei Vorschläge Herr märz das ist
viel zu wenig das ist viel zu wenig für
einen Oppositionsführer ihnen würde ich
dieses Land in dieser Situation nicht
anvertrauen
wollen ich würde die Fragen die sich
jetzt stellen einmal gerne konkret
machen weil dann plastisch wird über was
wir eigentlich reden und ich will das am
Beispiel der Stahlindustrie machen und
zwei Monate zurückschauen wir haben vor
zwei Monaten als Bundesregierung
gemeinsam mit dem Land
nordrheinwestfahen ein großes
Wirtschaftsprojekt dort angestoßen 2
Milliarden Euro für die Förderung von
tüsseng Grup um dem Unternehmen zu
ermöglichen künftig klimaneutralen Stahl
zu produzieren zurecht völlig zurecht
hat der Ministerpräsident
Nordrhein-Westfalens Hendrik wüst damals
diese einzigartige Chance Jobs für die
Zukunft zu sichern klimaneutralen Stahl
zu produzieren gefeiert als einen großen
Erfolg er hat das selber in den
Mittelpunkt gestellt zurecht es geht bei
tüssenrup um 27 000 Arbeitsplätze es
geht um die Familien dieser Menschen es
geht um die Wertschöpfung es geht um den
Wohlstand der Zukunft das sind
Investitionen die wir aus dem Klima und
transformationsfond getätigt haben und
wir sichern damit Zukunft in
Nordrhein-Westfalen mitten in Europa wir
brauchen mehr dieser Investitionen da
sind wir klar da ist der
Ministerpräsident in nordrin Westfalen
klar und es wäre gut wenn Sie sich das
einmal genauer anschauen würden und
Vorschläge machen könnten wie man an
dieser Stelle
vorankommt schauen wir schauen wir in
Saarland eine ganz ähnliche Situation
Ende Oktober sind dort 5000
Stahlarbeiter in Dillingen auf die
Straße gegangen weil sie das Ziel vor
Augen haben in den nächsten Jahren ihre
Produktion auf grünen Stahl umzustellen
und weil sie die Hoffnung verbinden
damit einen guten Job zu haben ein gutes
Leben zu haben und ein Auskommen zu
haben in dem man im mit woh im Wohlstand
leben kann die min Ministerpräsidentin
dort anke relinger hat zurecht gesagt
dass wir diese Klarheit brauchen dass
wir die Unterstützung des Bundes an der
Stelle brauchen weil die Menschen einen
Wunsch haben dass diese Transformation
gelingt und dass wir dafür das nötige
Geld zur Verfügung stellen das ist eine
gemeinsame Aufgabe die wir die wir haben
eine gemeinsame Aufgabe aus dem Bund aus
dem Land und es wäre schön wenn auch die
Union an der Stelle ein einziges Mal
konstruktive Vorschläge machen würde wie
man an dieser Stelle Politik ernsthaft
vor K GI es null vonen das ist zu
wenig völlig zurecht völlig zurecht hat
der Präsident des Bundesverbandes der
Industrie sifried Russwurm gesagt jetzt
darf die klimafreundliche Aufstellung
der Wirtschaft nicht stoppen das darf
jetzt nicht passieren deswegen brauchen
wir trotz des Urteils des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes die
Investitionen die jetzt nötig sind es
geht um Verantwortung die man jetzt
übernehmen muss deswegen ist es wichtig
jetzt den Haushalt voranzubringen und
gleichzeitig seriös darüber zu beraten
wo das Geld herkommt und auch da würde
ich Ihnen raten einmal das juviale
Feigen was sie hier an den Tag legen
sein zu lassen sich der Ernsthaftigkeit
der Lage zu stellen und ernsthaft
mitzuarbeiten wie man die Vorschläge auf
den Tisch legen kann die dann auch dazu
führen dass wir die Probleme die wir in
diesem Land haben ernsthaft und seriös
löst das wäre eine seriöse
Oppositionspolitik her märz von ihnen
ist an der Stelle leider nichts zu
erwarten wir dürfen uns nichts vormachen
global findet die neuaufst Stellung der
Industrie längst statt es wird massiv
investiert in ganz vielen Ländern auf
der Welt der globale Wettbewerb ist
längst ein Wettbewerb um die Cleantech
um die grünen Technologien der Zukunft
und die Frage die wir uns stellen müssen
ist wollen wir dass die in Zukunft hier
produziert werden es geht nicht um
abstrakte Zahlen es geht um
Unabhängigkeit um Sicherheit um
arbeitsplät um Menschen um die Familien
dieser Menschen und die haben es
verdient dass wir uns in Seriösität und
nicht mit juvialem fen um Ihre Fragen
des Lebens kümmern herzlichen
Dank Andreas audrch von bünes 90 die
Grünen mit Kritik an Friedrich märz und
der Aufforderung mehr mitzuarbeiten die
Opposition die CDU CSU haben ja diese
aktuelle Stunde beantragt jetzt die
andere Oppositionspartei di BS von den
Linken
fraktionsvorsitzer kgen nachem Urteil
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts steht die
Bundesregierung auf einem
finanzpolitischen Trümmerfeld
insbesondere der
Finanzminister sitzt steht da wie ein
begossener Pudel denn das ist ein
historisches Debakel meine Damen und
Herren für die Koalition und auch für
den Minister ganz persönlich Herr Linder
diesen verfassungswidrigen Haushalt
hätten sie niemals zulassen dürfen und
ich will sie selbst zitieren es ist
besser nicht zu regieren als falsch zu
regieren schlicht die Wahrheit und ich
will einfach sachlich feststellen
sachlich feststellen es ist doch
peinlich dass sie innerhalb von wenigen
Monaten das zweite Mal die rote Karte
aus karlsruh bekommen haben jeder
Bundesliga Spieler der solch eine
kartensammelmentalität an den Tag legt
der würde eine Denkpause erhalten ich
sag noch mal das höchste Negativurteil
verfassungswidrig haben sie aus karlsruh
bekommen und ich will sie daran erinnern
vor der Sommerpause wollten sie ihr
handwerklich miserables heizungsgesetz
mit Gewalt durch das Parlament prügeln
und der Abgeordnete Heilmann hat dann
dankenswerterweise in Karls geklagt mit
dem bekannten Erfolg und welche
Konsequenzen haben Sie daraus gezogen
ich erkenne kein ich erkenne kein die
haben das selbe Gesetz genauso wieder
vorgelegt und die abgeordn der Union
haben jetzt geklagt gegen ihrre
finanzpolitischen irgarten und was ist
wieder passiert rote Karte von karlsruhr
meine Damen und Herren diese peinliche
Pleite die hätten sie sich sparen können
will mal zwei Dinge zitieren Karls hat
gestern erklärt dass ein
Nachtragshaushalt nicht rückwirkend für
das feoruah aufgestellt werden kann
ehrlich gesagt das hätte man als
Regierung wissen können das hätte man
echt als Regierung Wissen könen und
Karls hat gestern ausgeführt dass das
umschichten der Mittel in den klimafond
nicht ausreichend begründet war das
hätte man als Regierung schlicht tun
müssen meine Damen und schlicht tun
müssen es ist keine Übertreibung zu
sagen sie versteh verstehen ihr Handwerk
nicht meine Damen und 60 Milliarden sind
ihn weggebrochen und das hat doch ganz
konkrete Folgen mein ausgabenstopp ist
das eine aber ich erwarte von Ihnen sie
haben jetzt gleich die Chance her Linder
konkrete Aussagen was jetzt passieren
soll keine schnellschüss hat a post
gesagt ja völlig richtig
Nachtragshaushalt ist doch am Horizont
zu erkennen sie haben dem Land
Versprechen gegeben mit ungedeckten
Schecks meine Damen und Herren das ist
die Wahrheit Milliarden für Intel
zugesagt was passiert denn jetzt mit den
Milliarden für Intel gibt die
institionen in die Bahn passieren die
jetzt Herr Aisch hat völlig zurecht auf
auf die notwendige Transformation der
Stahlindustrie hingewiesen völlig
richtig woher nehmen sie denn jetzt das
Geld was ist denn damit was passiert
denn jetzt zusätzlich wenn diese Gelder
weggefallen sind auch da richtig achin
Klimaschutz und sozialer Zusammenhalt
dürfen nicht die Verlierer sein aber sie
werden die Verlierer sein nach diesem
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil meine Damen
und Herren das ganze ist Ausdruck einer
unseriösen Finanzpolitik meine Damen und
Herren so kann man die stärkste
Volkswirtschaft Europas nicht regieren
meine Damen und Herren statt auf
haushaltswahrheit und haushaltsklarheit
zu setzen agieren sie mit
nebenhaushalten mit Schattenhaushalten
sonderschulden wie bei der Bundeswehr
die sie dann Sondervermögen nennen das
geht so alles nicht und das ist übrigens
nicht ganz neu manch Ministerpräsident
der Union wird auch noch ein paar
Probleme haben nach diesem Urteil und
das ist im übrigen ja eine Praxis
gewesen die schon einige Jahre länger
geht meine Damen und Herren sie haben
sich in einen finanzpolitischen
Irrgarten geflüchtet weil die
Widersprüche in ihrer Koalition größer
sind als manche Unfähigkeit dabei gebe
es doch wirklich auch zwei Auswege aus
dieser Krise die erste und das sagen ja
auch viele aus der SPD und auch von den
Grünen wir brauchen eine große
Steuerreform in diesem Land das do so
dringend notwendig unser jetziges System
ist so zukunftsfähig wie ein Faxgerät
meine Damen und Herren das ist die
Wahrheit und das wissen sie doch das
wissen sie doch aber sie beugen sich den
Christian Linder der sich lieber eine
rot Karte in karlsruh abholt als dass er
sie wirklich den Ruf bei den
Superreichen in irgendeiner Weise
einbüsel wird das ist die Wahrheit und
der zweite Punkt na ja die
Schuldenbremse Leben Zukunftsinvestition
Liebe Union liebe FDP sie beteuern immer
das Gegenteil aber es ist natürlich die
Wahrheit sie muss mindestens modifiziert
werden wir waren strickt dagegen wir
wollen jetzt nicht unbedingt recht haben
aber eins sieht doch jeder unser Land
ist an vielen Stellen baufällig und
marode geworden und wir brauchen
dringend Investitionen in Schulen in
Kliniken in Straßen in Brücken aber vor
allen Dingen auch Investitionen zur
Bekämpfung des Klimawandels in die
Energiewende und ich frage mich wofon
wollen Sie denn das jetzt bezahlen was
sie ursprünglich aus dem Fond machen
wollten das ist doch die zentrale Frage
meine Damen und Herren ich kann sie nur
auffordern steuern sie endlich um
arbeiten sie endlich seriös ansonsten
war das gestrige Urteil der Anfang vom
Ende dieser Bundesregierung herzlichen
Dank der Fraktionsvorsitzende von den
Linken hat durchaus auch Applaus von der
CDU CSU Fraktion bekommen für seine
Kritik an Christian Lindner jetzt kann
der Finanzminister selber sagen wie er
mit diesem Urteil aus Karlsruhe umgehen
will und wie die Bundesregierung darauf
reagieren will frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat sich
erstmals umfassend zu Ausnahmen von der
Schuldenbremse insbesondere auch im
Zusammenhang mit der Nutzung von
Sondervermögen befasst
zuvor gab es
unterschiedliche Einschätzungen und
Interpretationen bis heute wird in den
Ländern unterschiedlich mit der
Schuldenbremse gearbeitet die Praxis
unterscheidet sich das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat nun neue
Klarheit geschaffen und alle
Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützer der
Schuldenbremse müssen dies
begrüßen die
Bundesregierung sich stets zur
Schuldenbremse bekannt für manche gar zu
sehr mit dem zweiten Nachtrag zum
Haushalt
2021 bestand die Absicht nicht genutzte
Kreditermächtigungen einzusetzen um
pandemiebedingt ausgefallene
Investitionen nachzuholen auf dieses
Vorgehen hatten sich die die Koalition
bildenden Parteien bereits vor der
Regierungsbildung verständigt auch die
Vorgänger Regierung hat eine ähnliche
Vorgehensweise verschiedentlich
eingesetzt ist darauf hingewiesen worden
etwa beim Aufbau hilfeefond oder beim
digitalfond das Gesetz über den zweiten
Nachtrag
2021 hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht
nun verworfen deshalb hat die
Bundesregierung sofort die
offensichtlichen Konsequenzen gezogen
erstens die 60 Milliarden Euro
nettokreditermächtigungen im Klima und
Trans informtionsfond werden gelöscht
zweitens ich habe nach Paragraph 41 der
bundeshaushaltsordnung eine Sperre für
den KTF
entschieden damit zusätzliche
ausgabebelastungen für die Zukunft
ausgeschlossen werden und wir werden
einen neuen Wirtschaftsplan für den
Klima und
transformationsfond vorlegen der die
Vorgaben aus Karlsruhe berücksichtigt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen beklagt
wurde der
KTF geurteilt wurde
möglicherweise über die
Staatspraxis dies kann Auswirkungen auf
die
Haushaltspolitik in Bund und Ländern
generell haben deshalb wertet die
Bundesregierung das Urteil zur Stunde
sorgfältig aus es ist jetzt zu früh
bereits eine Debatte über grundlegende
Konsequenzen zu führen beispielsweise
gibt es eine Diskussion ja jetzt schon
darüber ob nicht die Schuldenbremse
generell aufgehoben werden soll ob sie
nicht generell gelockert werden soll und
nicht nur die
Linkspartei nicht nur die Linkspartei
tut das auch etwa der heutige vorsitzend
des Haushaltsausschusses des Deutschen
Bundestages hat vor der Bundestagswahl
noch als Kanzleramtsminister einen
Gastbeitrag veröffentlicht wo er die
Schuldenbremse wie war sie K aufweichen
wollte die Bundesregierung sieht es
anders wir wollen die neuewonnene
Rechtsklarheit nicht nutzen um die
Schuldenbremse zu schwächen sondern um
sie zu
stärken und dann über Steuererhöhungen
gesprochen hier von der Linken aber auch
in den Medien und auch in der CDU CSU
Bundestagsfraktion gab es ja ein
liebeugeln mit Steuererhöhung das ist
wie die immer gleiche Lösung auf der
Suche nach einem Problem tatsächlich hat
dieser Staat kein
Einnahmeproblem unsere
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit international steht
in Frage ein höchststeuerland das seine
steuerliche Belastung weiter anhebt
würde nicht nur den wirtschaftlichen
Aufschwung gefährden sondern würde
massiv auch die notwendigen
Investitionen verhindern die wir
beispielsweise in neue Technologie
Ben deshalb liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen bekennt sich die
Bundesregierung zu den Leitplanken ihres
Handelns einerseits die Schuldenbremse
bei der wir neue Rechtsklarheit haben
andererseits der Verzicht auf
Steuererhöhungen gerade diese Woche im
Deutschen
Bundestag gerade diese Woche im
Deutschen Bundestag die Stichworte sind
Wachstumschancen Gesetz und
zukunftsfinanzierungsgesetz belegen das
ja auch gleich wohl hat das Urteil
Konsequenzen auch in der längerfristigen
Perspektive für den Bundeshaushalt
es fehlt
nicht an der Einsicht sondern es fehlt
an den Taten und die werden wir jetzt
gemeinsam vorbereiten es läuft darauf
hinaus dass wir eine Praxis die in
Deutschland seit vielen Jahren besteht
verändern es ist ja seit vielen Jahren
so dass die Haushalte immer weiter
steigen und dass immer neue
Staatsaufgaben und Staatsausgaben
beschlossen werden und nun kommen wir an
einen Wendepunkt wir werden mit weniger
Geld wirksamere Politik machen müssen
als im vergangenen
Jahrzehnt wir haben kein
Einnahmeproblem sondern wir haben ein
Problem damit schon seit vielen Jahren
Prioritäten zu setzen wir haben uns zu
klaren Prioritäten bekannt wir wollen
eine Industrien naation bleiben die aber
klimaneutral wirtschaften will wir
wollen Aufstiegschancen durch Bildung
stärken und soziale Sicherheit auch nach
Schicksalsschlägen garantieren wir
wollen eine leistungsfähige
Infrastruktur und die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unseres Landes
Stärken all das ist möglich bei den
bestehenden Einnahmen ohne Flucht in
neue Schulden oder höhere Steuern wenn
wir die Prioritäten klären insofern kann
dieses Urteil nur eine Chance
sein das Wort hat der Kollege Alexander
dobrin für die CDU CS der Finanzminister
sieht das Urteil als eine Chance er hat
zum einen die 60 Milliarden für den
klimatransformationsfond gelöscht und
ist aber froh für die Klarheit aus
Karlsruhe jetzt Alexander Dobrind
csuhrte Kollegin und Kollegen sehr gete
Damen und Herren her
Bundesfinanzminister sie haben hier
einen Tweet wiederholt sinngemäß den
ihre Fraktion gestern abgesondert hat
der geheißen hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht stärkt die
Schuldenbremse und schafft Klarheit ich
frage mich ob der linksgrüne
Realitätsverlust endgültig auf sie
abgefärbt
ja das Verfassungsgericht es schafft
Klarheit aber es schafft vor allem
Klarheit über Ihre Ampelkoalition es
schafft Klarheit darüber dass sie keinen
Respekt haben gegenüber
verfassungsregeln im Parlament und den
Menschen in diesem
Land kheit dass sie keinen Plan haben
wie man dieses Land regiert und es
schafft Klarheit darüber dass sie jetzt
kein Geld mehr haben um ihre
ideologischen Projekte zu finanzieren
diese Klarheit schafft das
Verfassungsgericht so und dann stellen
sie sich hierhin Herr Finanzminister und
verkünden diese Regierung will die
Schuldenbremse nicht schwächen sondern
stärken ich darf Sie darauf hinweisen
dass bei diesem Satz sich keine einzige
Hand bei SPD und Grünen gerührt hat sind
sie eigentlich noch der Finanzminister
dieser Ampel oder minderheitsminister in
dieser
ampelregierung ja man kann diese man
kann diese Entscheidung in der Tat als
historisch bezeichnen und zwar in
dreifacher Hinsicht zum ersten Mal in
der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland wurde ein Bundeshaushalt für
verfassungswidrig und nichtig erklärt
zum ersten Mal wurde eine Koalition
ihrer kompletten finanziellen
Geschäftsgrundlage beraubt und sie
entzogen und zum ersten Mal versucht
eine Regierung so zu tun als hätte ein
60 Milliardenloch überhaupt keine
Auswirkung auf dem Bundeshaushalt sie
wollten Herr Finanzminister den
Transformation den Klima und
transformationsfor als Allzweckwaffe als
Steinbruch einsetzen er ist zum
Rohrkrepierer geworden das ist doch die
Wahrheit
hier Herr Post sie haben darauf
hingewiesen sie wollen jetzt ausgiebig
prüfen Sie wollen jetzt keine
Schnellschüsse sie wollen beraten
darüber und dann Entscheidungen treffen
der Haushaltsausschuss tagt aktuell seit
13 Uhr und sie wollen den Haushalt für
2024 einfach abschließen als hätte es
schlichtweg nichts gegeben sie stehen
gestern vor den Kameras mit dem
Bundeskanzler dem Vizekanzler dem
Finanzminister mit den drei ampelmännern
und sie erklären gemeinsam genau nichts
und das war das was auch jetzt wieder zu
Tage kam Herr
Bundesfinanzminister sie haben keinen
Plan und die Menschen fragen sich
zurecht ist es denn ihre Arroganz oder
ist es ihre Verzweiflung aber ich sage
Ihnen es ist es was die Menschen nicht
mehr ertragen können das mit Ignoranz
über die Sorgen hinwegen und für die
Krisen keine Lösungen mehr
zeigen wir haben es ihr gescheiterten
finanzmanöver von Anfang an anerkannt
dass es nicht funktionieren kann wir
haben Ihnen hier im Deutschen Bundestag
gesagt wörtlich finanzpolitisch
Finanzpolitik lässt sich nicht durch
finanz ik ersetzen weil das bedeutet
dass man sehr schnell sich außerhalb des
rechtsrahmes befindet sie haben alle
Warnungen auch die der Experten
ignoriert sie haben wörtlich gesagt das
sei der Ausdruck von Gestaltungswillen
nein meine Damen und Herren seit gestern
ist klar das ist nicht der Ausdruck von
Gestaltungswillen sondern das ist was
sie mit Mehrheit hier umsetzen ein
Betrug an der Schuldenbremse das ist was
sie gemacht
haben
aber vielleicht können sie sich ja auch
noch mal die Äußerungen anschauen die
von ihrem Koalitionspartner gestern
getätigt worden sind der Finanzminister
in badenwürtemberg Bayers der hat es ja
auf dem Punkt gebracht wörtliches Zitat
der Versuch von Christian Linder die
Quadratur des Kreises mit trixsereien
und sch Schattenhaushalten hinzubekommen
ist gescheitert diese aus sage sie
stimmt zwar aber ich finde sie sollten
sich alle mit ihrer Schadenfreude
zurückhalten es sind doch ihre
linksgrünen wunschprojekte die die
Grundlage für diese
haushaltsmanipulation überhaupt erst
waren sPD Grüne FDP sie haben sich ihren
Koalitionsvertrag mit rechtswidrigen mit
verfassungswidrigen finanztrixsereien
erkauft und deswegen ist es ist auch
nicht irgendein Haushalt den das
Bundesverfassungsgericht gestern für
nichtig erklärt hat es ist das
Gründungsdokument ihrer Koalition dass
sich gestern in Luft aufgelöst hat ihre
koalitionsidee ist schlichtweg
Geschichte befreien sie doch dieses Land
von dieser
ampeldramatik Alexander dobrin von der
CSU in einer recht heftig geführten
Debatte inzwischen wo es doch um sehr
grundsät es geht und grundsätzliche
Kritik an der Schuldenbremse und an der
Art wie die Ampelkoalition mit dem
Urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerechts Gerichtes von
gestern umgeht jetzt Matthias Mirsch SPD
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lieber Herr Kollege
Dobrind ich glaube die Situation ist zu
ernst als dass man in solchen Situation
übereinander herfallen sollte ich frage
sie wenn sie von
linksgrünen
wunschprojekten sprechen sind Milliarden
Investitionen in die Deutsche Bahn
rotgrüne
wunschprojekte sind Milliarden
Investitionen in die Gebäudesanierung
dieses Landes rotgrüne
wunschprojekte ist das Investieren in
die erneuerbaren Energien ein rotgrünes
Wunschprojekt ichfürchte ja aber nur in
ihrem Sinne dringend notwendige
Investitionen in die Zukunft dieses
Landes liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und wenn ich lese in einigen
Kommentaren dieses Urteil schafft mehr
generationerechtigkeit dann mache ich
dort ein
Fragezeichen denn die
generationerechtigkeit und ich erinnere
mich sehr genau an die Diskussionen hier
die wir 2009 geführt haben die
generationerechtigkeit nur fiskalptisch
beurteilt ist aus unserer
keine Form der
generationerechtigkeit nicht
umsonst nicht umsonst spricht man von
nachhaltiger Entwicklung wenn man drei
Säulen betrachtet die finanzpolitische
die eine Säule die
sozialpolitische und die
ökologische und ich weiß noch dass auch
der Bundestagspräsident damals Norbert
Lammert mit mir und anderen zusammen
gegen dies schenbremse gestimmt haben
weil wir diese dieses Gleichgewicht
damals nicht abgebildet gesehen haben
und deswegen sage ich ganz bewusst Herr
mer sie können sich das hier heute auf
die fahen schreiben aber das trägt nicht
lang es trägt schon in diesen Minuten
nicht weil ich schon auch aus
schwarzregierten Bundesländern die
großen Sorgen vernehme die jetzt dieser
Schritt nach sich ziehen wird wenn wir
in einer
absuten
Krisen nicht als Staat
Handlungsfähigkeit beweisen dann wird
dieses Land in richtige Schwierigkeiten
kommen und
deswegen deswegen selbstverständlich ist
diese
verfassungsgerichtsentscheidung zu
respektieren und zu akzeptieren aber vor
Jahren hat genau dieses Gericht uns
aufgeben wel gabe wir mit der mit der
Bekämpfung des von Menschen gemachten
Klimawandels haben und im übrigen
Kollegin und Kollegen der AFD das
unterscheidet uns wir akzeptieren und
werden diese
verfassungsgerichtsentscheidung umsetzen
bis heute kämpfen sie mit jedem Antrag
in Sachen Klimaschutz gegen dieses
Urteil und das ist verfassungswidrig was
sie hier tun Liebe Kolleginen und
Kollegen der
Bundesfinanzminister dieses Urteil
beinhaltet auch eine riesige Chance und
ich bin mir sehr sicher dass die Ampel
diese Chance trotz aller Unterschiede
möglicherweise in der Bewertung auch
wahrnehmen wird wir uns muss es gelingen
dass wir die
Zukunftsinvestitionen die wir im Klima
und transformationsfond abgebildet haben
auch weiterfahren können das ist
elementar wir
müssen das Klimaschutzgesetz und die
Rechtssprechung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts dazu umsetzen
und wenn wir Klimaschutz tatsächlich in
dieser Gesellschaft durchsetzen wollen
dann brauchen wir
Zukunftsinvestitionen um den sozialen
Zusammenhalt in diesem Land zu sichern
liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und jetzt höre ich von einigen
na ja da kann es ja dann die Schraube
des CO2 Preises geben da sage ich dieser
CO2 Preis wir wir für viele viel viel
stärker als eine
Steuererhöhung denn es werden die Leute
unter Druck kommen die nicht Förderung
jetzt genießen können in neue
Heizungsanlagen in neue Mobilität und
deswegen nur den Verzicht übrig lassen
das wollen wir nicht liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir
brauchen wir brauchen deutliche
Förderprogramme die in die Milliarden
gehen damit der für die breite Schicht
dieser Gesellschaft überhaupt möglich
ist nur so wird Klimaschutz
funktionieren insofern es werden
anstrengende Beratung aber es werden
Beratung die diese Ampel auf alle Fälle
stemmen kann davon sind wir überzeugt
und wir werden uns als Sozialdemokratie
voll dort hinein beeben ich danke für
Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit anstrengende Beratungen
denn eins ist klar durch das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes hat die
Koalition weniger Spielraum oder wie der
Bundesfinanzminister sagte wir werden
mit weniger Geld wirksamere Politik
machen müssen als in den letzten Jahren
jetzt Felix bin gr Kollegin und Kollegen
das Urteil ist bekannt aber wenn ich mir
die Debatte heute hier so anschaue und
anhöre dann ist mir nicht klar ob die
Tragweite und die Komplexität des
Urteils eigentlich allen schon so ganz
bekannt ist es wird doch gestern
Abend es wird doch gestern Abend der ein
oder andere CDU Finanzminister in den
Länder oder der ein od andere CDU
Ministerpräsident in den Ländern sehr
sehr sehr genau nachgeguckt haben Moment
was bedeutet das denn eigentlich für uns
und es werden doch auch ganz ganz viele
geguckt haben was bedeutet denn
eigentlich jetzt eine solche Sperre im
Klima und transformationsfond und eine
solche Unsicherheit über 60 Milliarden
Euro geplanter programmausgaben für Sie
persönlich und ich glaube wir brauchen
die nötige Ernsthaftigkeit und auch das
nötige Verantwortungsgefühl in dieser
Debatte wer wie ich aus einer Region
kommt
in der Strukturwandel früher vor allem
Verlust bedeutet hat in der industrielle
wertschäpfung verloren gegangen ist und
nur in Teilen durch Dienstleistung und
Akademisierung aufgefangen werden konnte
W einer solchen Region kommt kann sich
den Leichtsinn mancher Debatte hier gar
nicht
leisten wenn wir
wissen wenn wir
wissen dass die Märkte der Zukunft
klimaneutral sind wenn wir wissen dass
alle inklusive blackw und anderen
ausschließlich noch und prioritär in
grüne Märkte in grüne Vorhaben
investieren dann wissen wir doch dass
die Zukunftsfähigkeit dieser
Gesellschaft und ihres
Wirtschaftsstandorts entschieden davon
abhängt entscheidend davon abhängt dass
wir diese Transformation bewerkstelligen
können und wenn wir das wissen und wenn
wir das wissen dann ist doch vollkommen
klar dass egal wie wir die Wege finden
wir Wege finden müssen den Umbau unserer
Gesellschaft zur klimaneutralen
Produktion zu schaffen denn ansonsten
ist in Duisburg in Dillingen in
Bremerhafen in Ludwigshafen die
Botschaft klar entweder wir bauen um
oder wir bauen ab wir wollen umbauen sie
wollen abbauen das ist doch die Lage der
die wir heute diskutieren sie wollen
abbauen und Herr
März herrärz sie haben diese sie haben
diese Debatte mit zwei
Falschbehauptungen begonnen die erste
Falschbehauptung bezieht sich auf das
was wir vor der Sommerpause erlebt haben
das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat mit
nichten abschließend in einem
Hauptsacheverfahren entschieden
entschieden dass es nicht
verfassungsgemäßer ich bin ja nur ein
schnöder Haushaltspolitiker ich bin ja
gar kein Jurist und trotzdem ist mir die
Unterscheidung klar das
bundesverfassungsgricht hat in
einzweiliger Anordnung entschieden es
könnte sein und deswegen ist das
Verfahren so gemacht worden und und die
zweite Falschbehauptung ist dass sie
sagen diese Regierung macht weiter als
wäre nichts geschehen ich weiß nicht ob
sie schon Rücksprache hatten mit ihren
Kollegen im Haushaltsausschuss wir saßen
da gestern ich glaub bis kurz vor
magnacht zusammen und wir haben
entschieden um die Minderheiten Rechte
also ihre Rechte zu berücksichtigen dass
wir jetzt die Bereinigungssitzung
durchführen aber dass natürlich nächste
Woche eine Anhörung gibt und dass ein
entsprechender Beschluss des Haushalts
als Grundlage dafür dass wir noch in
diesem Jahr einen Haushalt verabschieden
im Bundesrat beraten und damit ins
gesetzbad schreiben können dass wir das
erreichen können damit wir nicht in die
vorläufige Haushaltsführung kommen sie
wollen das riskieren das ist nicht
verantwortungsbewusst aber es gibt aber
es gibt tatsächlich her März es gibt
tatsächlich her März eine Parallele
zwischen dem Sommer und dem was wir
jetzt diskutieren sie haben es beim
Gebäude Energiegesetz obwohl sie sich so
aufgeplustert haben nicht mal geschafft
einen einzigen Änderungsantrag zum
gebäudeenergies zu formulieren und heute
haben wir heute haben wir im
Haushaltsausschuss die Ankündigung der
Unionsfraktion gehört sie wird keine
eigenen Änderungsanträge einbringen und
sich so der konstruktiven Beratung
dieses Bundeshaushalts verweigern ich
finde das sollen alle wissen sie machen
hier groß bei High groß V high aber wenn
es entscheidend ist dann liefern sie
nicht ich glaube das können und das
müssen sie besser in einer so
schwierigen
Lage
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja das
Urteil des Verfassungsgerichts wird
weitreichende Auswirkung haben ich kann
uns allen nur empfehlen heute keine zu
großen Vorfestlegungen zu treffen und
noch nicht zu viele Dinge auszuschließen
oder absolut klar als Ziel zu haben wir
haben seit gestern ein Urteil und wir
beraten das jetzt in der notwendigen
Ernsthaftigkeit die wir
brauchen aber ich kann Sie nur bitten
sich zu fragen was ihre ortung ist das
Problem D wir haben haben wir hier nicht
als Ampel oder als grüne sondern wir
haben das als Volkswirtschaft und
Gesellschaft und sie müssen entscheiden
ob sie Teil der Lösung sein wollen oder
nicht felix bannerchack ist Mitglied im
Haushaltsausschuss und er referierte
auch darüber wie der Haushaltsausschuss
jetzt umgehen soll darüber gab es ja
einen Streit die Bereinigungssitzung hat
gestern stattgefunden aber es soll noch
eine zusätzliche Sitzung geben in der
folgenden Woche damit man noch weiter
beraten kann anlässlich der Folgen des
bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteils jetzt
Johannes Vogel FDP erster
parlamentarischer
Geschäftsführer die Wortbeiträge
derjenigen die diese aktuelle Stunde
beantragt haben die Kolleginen und
Kollegen von der Union und insbesondere
von ihnen geschätzter Kollege Alexander
drobind auch nur so beurteilen konnte
dass sie die notwendige Ernsthaftigkeit
nach diesem wegweisenden Urteil gestern
vermissen lassen und das gleich
erstens weil die Union jetzt ja
offenkundig die Arbeit im
Haushaltsausschuss komplett eingestellt
hat das Gegenteil von dem was jetzt
angezeigt ist liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zweitens weil die Union sich
plötzlich als großer Anwälte der
Schuldenbremse aufspielt und der
Finanzminister eben zur recht schon
darauf hingewiesen der
heutige vorsitzen des
Haushaltsausschusses hat noch kurz vor
der Bundestagswahl als er noch kanzleram
ister war zum Schleifen der
Schuldenbremse aufgerufen die Frage wie
die Union zur Schuldenbremse steht hängt
ganz offenbar davon ab wann man sie
fragt die Schuldenbremse verdient mehr
Ernsthaftigkeit liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der
Union und drittens weil es ja lohnt sich
einmal kurz anzuschauen wer eigentlich
von diesem Urteil des
Verfassungsgerichtes genau betroffen ist
die letzte Bundesregierung die große
koalitionter Führung der Union hat von
den Corona bedingten Kredit mit
Ermächtigung ein dickes zweistelliges
Milliardenpaket in den Klima und
transformationsfond übertragen die
unionsgeführte Landesregierung
schleswig- Holstein hat ein Corona und
notkreditprogramm aufgelegt und
finanziert daraus unter anderen
Bildungsinvestitionen sie hat zu
übertragen die unionsgeführte
Landesregierung in Nordrhein-Westfalen
hat gleich nach ihrem Regierungswechsel
ein Ukraine Sondervermögen Milliarden
schwer aufgelegt und sie finanziert
daraus jetzt Übertragung unter anderem
Förderung der Energieeffizienz in
Krankenhäusern liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich verstehe ja dass eine
Volkspartei ein breites Meinungsspektrum
vertreten muss aber so viel Dialektik
hätte ich nur den Marxisten zugetraut
Liebe Kolleginen und Kollegen von der
Union
nein lassen wir doch diese
parteipolitische Betrachtung und schauen
wir mit größerer Ernsthaftigkeit auf
dieses
Urteil schauen wir mit größerer
Ernsthaftigkeit auf dieses Urteil nach
allem was man hört und was berichtet
wird hat ja unter anderem der ehemalige
Bundestagspräsident Wolfgang schäubler
auch in der Fraktionssitzung der Union
gestern zurecht darauf
hingewiesen die
Schuldenbremse ist ein Gebot der
Generationengerechtigkeit und was das
Verfassungsgericht gemacht hatit ist es
schafft jetzt noch mehr Klarheit bei der
Auslegung der Schuldenbremse und diese
Klarheit ist gut liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen weil wir uns alle jetzt darauf
einstellen
können die
Schuldenbremse war eine Wegscheide für
Generationengerechtigkeit bei der
Einführung in unsere Verfassungsordnung
und das Verfassungsgericht hat zurecht
in zwei wegweisenden urteilen diese
Woche und vor einiger Zeit darauf
hingewiesen dass wir künftigen
Generationen sowohl ein stabiles Klima
als auch stabile Finanzen Schulden und
das ist richtig liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das ist ein Gebot der
Nachhaltigkeit und dem müssen wir
gerecht werden und deshalb ist jetzt die
ganze Politik auf allen Ebenen Bund und
Länder gefordert drei Dinge zu tun
erstens zu priorisieren ja im Klima und
transformationsfond und in Wahrheit auch
bei den Staatsausgaben darüber hinaus
zweitens Klimapolitik zu betreiben die
wir betreiben können weil lieber Kollege
Matthias Mirsch natürlich das wichtigste
Instrument zum Klimaschutz doch der
Dichte Deckel für CO2 der
Zertifikatehandel ist und sein muss und
dieser natürlich jetzt noch mehr an
Bedeutung gewinnt liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen sein wir da doch ehrlich und
drittens
drittens weil
wir uns die Frage stellen müssen erstens
wie können wir dafür sorgen dass der
große Ausgabeposten dauerhaft im
Bundeshaushalt soziale Sicherungssysteme
in diesem Land dauerhaft stabil
finanziert sind und zweitens wie können
wir uns dafür wie können wir uns darum
kümmern dass auch die Einnahmenseite des
Haushaltes sich durch gute
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung durch
Wirtschaftswachstum positiv entwickelt
in diesem Land und dafür können wir eine
ganze Menge tun Freihandelspolitik ist
Wirtschaftspolitik die kein Geld kostet
gute Rahmenbedingung für Wirtschaft und
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit ist
Wirtschaftspolitik und damit auch gute
Haushaltspolitik für die wir nicht Geld
ausgeben müssen sondern was die
Unternehmen in diesem Land
erwirtschaften stimmen Sie gerne morgen
im Wachstum chancengesetz und den
zukunftsfanzierungsgesetz zu liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
dass diese Koalition einbringt und indem
wir z.B den Unternehmen in diesem Land
weniger bürokratische Fesseln anlegen
auch ein Weg auf den sich diese
Koalition gemacht hat die Schuldenbremse
ist Ausdruck dessen dass die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger sich darauf verlassen können
das für den Staat gilt für Sie auch gilt
nämlich dass sie mit dem Geld auskommen
was sie haben dass wir das gestärkt
haben ist eine Chance wenn wir alle
verantwortungsbewusst mit dir umgehen
vielen
Dank Johannes Vogel appellierte an das
Miteinander auch der Opposition in
diesen schwierigen Zeiten das nächste
Wort hat Dr Matthias Middelberg von der
CDU CSU stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der eben noch im
Gespräch mit Friedrich Merz zu sehen war
vielleicht hat der
unionsfraktionsvorsitzende ihm noch
etwas mit auf den Weg gegeben
Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich finde einige der reden der
Regierungsvertreter und ich spreche auch
ausdrücklich den Finanzminister an
hätten hier angesichts der Sachlage
angem sein könen das sage ich ganz
offen ich finde das sehr wundersam dass
sie immer gleich mindestens mal schon im
zweiten Satz mit dem Finger auf die
Opposition zeigen was hier und da
irgendwie schief gelaufen wäre in den
vergangenen Jahren oder in irgendwelchen
Landesregierung die jetzt auch Probleme
haben oder dies oder jenes statt mal
einmal aufzunehmen dass es gestern eine
Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts über ihre
Regierungspolitik über ihren Haushalt
gab über nichts anderes wurde
entschieden erstmals ist ein Haushalt
ein
Bundeshaushalt einer Bundesregierung vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht für
verfassungswidrig und dann auch gleich
für komplett nichtig erklärt worden das
ist historisch bislang einmalig hier
wurde vorgetragen dass wir gegen den KTF
geklagt hätten oder gegen die
Klimapolitik beklagt worden sei der KTF
das ist völliger Blödsinn gegen den
klimafong hat hier niemand gekl da
würden wir auch gar nicht gegen klagen
geklagt worden ist gegen den
Nachtragshaushalt und die Art und Weise
wie sie 60 Milliarden
Kreditermächtigungen in
verfassungswidriger Weise übertragen
haben dagegen haben wir
geklagt
und ich will Ihnen sehr deutlich sagen
das war ja die grundabsprache ihrer
Koalition sie haben sich zusammengesetzt
und haben gesagt die SPD kriegt viel
Geld für Soziales die Grünen kriegen
viel Geld für Klima und die FDP kriegt
zwei Zusagen nämlich es gibt keine
Steuererhöhung und die Schuldenbremse
wird eingehalten und dann haben Sie
gemerkt oh Kacke wir haben nicht genug
Geld so ja das kann man so deutlich
sagen wir haben nicht genug Geld und
jetzt müssen wir mal gucken wo wir was
hernehmen und da kam der kluge Hinweis
da sind ja noch 60 Milliarden übrig von
den coronageldern von den Ermächtigungen
aus der alten Regierung die können wir
uns einfach mal übertragen wird ja wohl
keiner merken und dann wurde uns
vorgehalten vom Bundesfinanzminister und
das ist nämlich falsch Herr D das sage
ich Ihnen ganz deutlich das haben sie
den Blödsinn haben sie ja auch erzählt
gestern vorlaufender Kamera diese Praxis
hat es vorher nämlich nicht gegeben
vorher wurde jahresgenau abgerechnet
hören Sie mal sehr genau zu her und
prüfen Sie das nach an dem Punkt werde
ich nämlich jetzt sehr
empfindlich das Bundesverfassungsgericht
hat ihren Haushalt kassiert weil sie
gegen das jährlichkeitsprinzip verstoßen
haben vorher gab es auch Sondervermögen
und es gab Übertragungen in solche
Sondervermögen auch in Zeiten der
Unionsregierung aber innerhalb eines
Jahres und die wurden als sie vorausgabt
wurden genau auf das Jahr hin
abgerechnet sie haben in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag eine Regel
ausdrücklich reingeschrieben dass sie
von jetzt ab neu buchen maßgeblich sein
sollte nicht der Kredit zu dem Zeitpunkt
wo er den Bundeshaushalt belastet
sondern zu dem Zeitpunkt wo sie die
Kredite rüberschieben vom Kernhaushalt
in ihr Sondervermögen und das war die
Unzulässigkeit und das hat das
Verfassungsgericht kassiert und das
müssen sie ich sag's Ihnen jetzt mal so
deutlich in ihre Birne
kriegen ja so ist es so und wenn Sie das
nämlich einmal verstanden haben wenn sie
das jetzt einmal begriffen haben dann
merken sie dass ihr ganzer WSF ihr
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond dieser
super doppelwumps mit 200 Milliarden
dass der genauso von diesem Urteil des
Verfassungsgerichts infiziert ist das
sage ich Ihnen ganz deutlich deswegen
und jetzt komme ich zum Punkt ist es
völlig
unverantwortlich in dieser Woche und
auch sonst jetzt irgendwie planmäßig
weiter über den Haushalt 2024 zu
verhandeln das ist komplett
verantwortungslos sie haben ja eben Herr
Post richtigerweise gesagt es darf jetzt
keine Schnellschüsse geben wenn sie
jetzt verhandeln über den Bundeshaushalt
2024 ohne dass sie das Urteil wirklich
ausgewertet haben und jetzt wissen was
ist wirklich die verfassungsrechtliche
Auswirkung dieses Urteils dann ist es
grobfahrlässig wenn sie jetzt weiter
über diesen Haushalt in dem geplanten
Verfahren verhandeln das kann ich ihn
nur sagen sie laufen in den nächsten
Verfassungsbruch hinein sehenden Auges
nein sie müssen sich jetzt ehrlich
machen wie friedich merärz das gesagt
hat Zeit ende jetzt wirklich richtig
umsetzen umschichten im Haushalt
wirklich umbauen herr Vogel hat ja
ausnahmsweise einen Punkt zurecht
angesprochen dann machen Sie doch mal
was in der Sozialpolitik Herr Lindner
hat zurecht gesagt Millionen im
Bürgergeld die erwerbsfähig sind könnten
Arbeiten tun es aber nicht eine
riesenaugabe für diese Regierung nur
100000 die sie mehr in Arbeit Brechten
aus dem Bürgergeld hinaus würde dem
Bundeshaushalt 3
Milliarden 100000 das Rechnen sie mal
hoch auf welche Beträge sie dann kommen
herzlichen
Dank Matthias Middelberg von der Union
der noch mal stark die Ampelkoalition
angreift der Finanzminister hatte ja
gesagt es seit zu früh um eine Debatte
über grundlegende Konsequenzen aus
diesem Urteil zu führen ich bin sicher
wenn sie das stogische vorabok noch
einmal sehen wird ihn auffallen dass das
mit der parlamentarischen Ausdrucksweise
nicht immer ganz so klappt ich bitte das
einfach ein wenig zu
[Applaus]
berücksichtigen das Wort hat Sonja
eichwede für die SPD
Fraktion sonja eichwedde ist die letzte
Rednerin in dieser aktuellen
Stunde sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
werrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen
Fraktion zunächst möchte ich sagen wir
diskutieren oder wir sollten diskutieren
über das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts zum
Nachtragshaushalt bei einiger reden der
Fraktion die eben gerade diese Debatte
angemeldet hat haben wir nicht das
Gefühl dass wir über das Urteil eines
Bundes des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes
reden sondern dass man sich eher in
einem Fußballstadion befindet das ist
dieser Debatte und dem Urteil nicht
angemessen
das gestrige Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
selbstverständlich eine enorme Bedeutung
für die
Regierungskoalition der
Bundesfinanzminister der Bundeskanzler
Bundeswirtschaftsminister haben dazu
gestern Stellung genommen und
unmittelbar Konsequenzen gezogen es hat
große Auswirkung auch auf uns als
Bundestagsabgeordnete auf den Bundestag
und auf die gesamte Bundesrepublik ist
es angeklungen es wird auch große
Auswirkung haben gerade auf die
länderhaushälte diese Art und Weise
unseres Handelns wird sich nun
höchstwahrscheinlich ändern ist
politische Gestaltungskraft wird anders
werden in haushaltsverhandlung in
Haushaltsaufstellung aber dafür ist es
doch gerade wichtig dass wir jetzt die
Gründe des Urteils analysieren auslegen
und gucken wie wir mit diesen umgehen
das ist verantwortliches Handeln das ist
Regierungshandeln aber einen Tag nach
einer Entscheidung des des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts hier eine
Debatte zu machen und dann anscheinend
offensichtlich nicht mal die
Urteilsgründe ordentlich gelesen zu
haben und sich mit dem Inhalt des
Urteils auseinandergesetzt zu haben das
lässt doch wirklich die Demut vor der
entfassung vor der Entscheidung unseres
verfassungshüters
vermissen das Urteil ist die erste
Entscheidung zu Artikel 115 der im Jahr
2019 neu in das Grundgesetz gekommen ist
es hat damals eine unglaublich große
Tragweite und es ist eben jetzt auch
seriös zu behandeln und es ist die
Prämisse auch der Demut hier genau
rechtlich vorzugehen und es eben nicht
politisch zu
instrumentalisieren denn
was was wollen Sie denn mit dieser
Debatte es sind viele ernsthafte Fragen
aufgegeben worden eine Antwort kann man
einen Tag später nicht geben und sie
haben es doch in ihren Redebeiträgen
auch gar nicht versucht wir werden es
prüfen wir werden mit der Regierung
handeln und wir werden bei zukünftigen
Haushaltsaufstellung auch entsprechend
der
Aufstellung für Haushalte und der
Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes
selbstverständlich Handeln es GT hier
nicht zu poltern sondern es GT hier die
eines Rechtsstaates und eines anderen
Verfassungsorgans gegenüber auch
entsprechend zu wahren um an
Problemlösung zu arbeiten und dafür sind
wir doch gewählt um an Problemlösung zu
arbeiten wir haben auf der einen Seite
die Schuldenbremse wir haben die Frage
von
Generationengerechtigkeit diese Frage
haben wir aber doch auch bei Frage der
Klimagerechtigkeit auch vor dem Hinblick
des Urteils auf das heute mehrfach
verwiesen wurde vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht eben gerade zum
Klima aus dem Jahr 2021 und Herr Dobrind
dass sie dann hier von quasi politischen
ideologischen Vorhaben sprechen wenn es
um wirtschaftsansiedlung geht wenn es
darum geht die Frage zu gestalten wie
wir unsere Wirtschaft umbauen gerade vor
dem Urteil vor dem Hintergrund des
Urteils des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
was eben auch im Jahre 21 gesprochen
wurde lässt das eben auch zusätzlich
noch mal den notwendigen respektade
gegenüber der Rechtsprechung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts
vermissen was mir
aber was mir aber auch sehr wichtig ist
anzusprechen insbesondere in dieser
Frage zeigt dieses Urteil doch gerade
auch wo wir in einer Situation sind wo
insbesondere eine Fraktion in diesem
Haus immer wieder Zweifel an der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit immer wieder Zweifel
an der Funktionsfähigkeit
rechtsstaatlicher Organisation sehen
will dass die Gewaltenteilung
funktioniert dass andere
Verfassungsorgane auch harte
Entscheidungen treffen dass wir unsere
Ämter alle mit großem Engagement und
Pflicht gemäßem Ermessen entsprechend
ausüben und dass wir auch in schwierigen
Zeiten uns darauf verlassen können dass
wir eben hier einen guten Hüter unserer
Verfassung haben wir werden jetzt mit
den Konsequenzen des Urteils umgehen wir
werden die Rechtssprechung auslegen das
gebietet eben auch der Respekt vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht aber große
Teile dieser Debatte haben eben diesen
Respekt vermissen lassen vielen
Dank Sonja eichwede von der SPD die
letzte Rednerin in dieser aktuellen
Stunde die damit beendet ist die
aktuelle Stunde zum
Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil zum
Nachtragshaushalt